is an unbelievable nightmare for mr.
Woodfox
many of these years mr. Woodfox had to
litigate this case without
representation and he did that from 1972
and to the early 90s when he was able to
get lawyer so for about 20 years
he bore the weight of this case by
himself and then for an additional 20
years there have been teams of lawyers
involved in this case and the state has
had a pattern of engaging in dilatory
practices and so the idea on the part of
the state is every time there is a
victim for victory from mr. Woodfox they
filed something with the courts to try
to delay proceedings and so that has
happened yet again and it has been a 42
year battle of the state delaying the
inevitable this is an innocent man and
it is time for this injustice to come to
an end and he spent a great deal at that
time in solitary confinement in person
hasn't he tell us a little bit about the
conditions that he's been injured
certainly he spent almost the entire 43
years in solitary confinement on his
conditions have been consistent for
about 43 years there was a change about
a month ago because she was Rhian died
today for weeks his conditions have been
even more extreme than they were for the
43 years prior to today for that entire
time mr. Wood Fox has been housed in a
cell that is approximately 6 by 9 he
lives in the cell all alone he is not
allowed out of the cell for meals he's
not allowed out for church he's not
allowed to participate in any activities
with other inmates he's not allowed to
even make a trip to the library if he
does come out of the cell to exercise he
leaves that cell only to be put into
another cage so his exercise cell is
also enclosed very much like his
solitary cell in his cell he has a bed
or he has a very thin mattress he has a
toilet and he has a sink for the
majority of these 43 years
there were bars on the outside of the
cell that would allow him to hear
screams of agony to overhear fights and
arguments at least to see the guards
walk the halls but for the last four
weeks since he's been rien died today is
actually living behind a steel door it
is all metal and so there are no bars on
that door and he's not able to see or
hear anything outside so it's very much
like being sealed away inside of a box
given those conditions he's been living
in for so many years how do you think he
might cope with being released
well mr. Wood Fox has a team of
incredible supporters and we have all
committed there many of us involved with
this case to not allow him to
deteriorate under these conditions and
so his mind has been constantly
challenged he we sent him books to read
we sent him puzzles to work out we
monitor some of his letters and we can
tell by his handwriting when his
condition is turning for the worst we
make sure to visit and continuously
allow him to use his mind and his legs
and it's all so that he doesn't lose
circulation and so in terms of what
happens when he transitioned out of this
he walks into the loving care of many
citizens in Louisiana who understand
that he has been dealt an injustice and
we are here to help him rebuild his life
he has a daughter who he has are
reunited with and he is looking forward
to opportunities to get to know his
daughter and his grandchildren um there
are many professional people involved
with this case so there are resources to
assist him with his needs whatever they
may be and he will fall into the hands
of people who will protect him and make
sure that he marches on to victory this
has been a horrible experience and
there's a lesson in this for many many
other inmates they're about 80,000
people right now in the United States
who are being held under conditions just
like mr. Woodfox
this is not an isolated case this is
starting to become a trend in the way we
operate our prison system his is
a little different in the sense that
he's been housed for so long
43 years is the longer end of this but
this is certainly not a new phenomenon
in Corrections in the United States